as on Sunday in bandar Bay Kenya and
attacked by al-qaeda affiliate Al
Shabaab resulted in the death of a US
service member and two department of
defense contractors while wounding two
other American personnel on behalf of
the entire department our thoughts are
with the family and friends of Army
Specialist Henry Mayfield jr. he was in
Kenya in support of operation Octavio
working to protect American interests in
the region and improve security and
stability alongside our Kenyan partners
we honor him and his colleagues who lost
their lives and assure you that the
perpetrators of this attack will be
brought to justice the United States
conducted over 60 airstrikes against
al-shabaab safe havens and assets last
year and our forces continue to provide
training and counterterrorism support to
our East African partners at the man
debate airfield to help them in the
fight moving to Iran at this time our
top priorities remain first the safety
and security of American personnel and
our partners and second our readiness to
conduct operations to respond to Iranian
aggression since the strike I've spoken
with the commanders on the ground to
ensure they have the resources they need
to protect their people and prepare for
any contingencies as a result we've
increased our force protection postures
across the region and will continue to
reposition and bolster our forces as
necessary to protect our people our
interests and our facilities as I
mentioned to you yesterday we have
received widespread support for our
actions from our allies and partners in
the region and we will continue to work
with them to protect our gains against
Isis I've been in constant communication
with my counterparts and have called on
them to stand with us in the defense of
coalition forces in Iraq working through
NATO the defeat Isis coalition and with
our partners on the ground we continue
to bolster Iraqi institutions to ensure
the lasting defeat of Isis as we defend
our people and interests let me
reiterate that the United States is not
seeking a war with Iran but we are
prepared to finish one we are seeking a
diplomatic solution but first this will
require Iran to de-escalate it will
require the regime to come to the table
with the goal of preventing further
blood
and it will require them to cease their
malign activities throughout the region
as I've said we are open to having this
discussion with them but we were just as
prepared to deliver a forceful response
to defend our interests finally the
American people should know that their
safety is in the hands of the strongest
most capable military in the world the
men and women of our armed forces should
know that we were standing with them and
will continue to support them as they
meet and overcome today's threats from
aligned actors including Iran and it's
proxies militias our partners should
know that we remain committed to our
strategic priorities in the Middle East
deterring Iranian bad behavior
sustaining the enduring defeat of Isis
and supporting Iraq as it becomes a
strong and independent nation and the
architects of Terror should know that we
will not tolerate attacks against
America's people and interests and will
exercise our right to self-defense
should that become necessary once again
with that I'll open this up for some
questions Thank You Secretary to clarify
one thing and you said earlier that the
US continues to engage Isis in Syria
have has the anti-isis campaign in Syria
been affected at all by this and then
secondly there seems to be continued
confusion among Iraqi officials about
this draft Lateran there was a televised
appearance by Mahdi earlier today in
which he sort of laid out what he said
was a signed letter that the Iraqis got
those are his words and he suggested
that another letter should be sent what
have you done and are you continuing to
do to clear up what you said yesterday
was a mistake our policy has not changed
we are not leaving Iraq and a draft
unsigned letter does not constitute a
policy change and there is no sign
letter to the best of my knowledge I've
asked the question so there may be
people trying to create confusion but we
should focus on this much what I said a
few times now our policy has not changed
we are in Iraq
[Applause]
independent and prosperous country Isis
in Syria I've gotten no report from a
commander saying that we've had a
material impact on our ability to engage
Isis along with our SDF partners leaders
questions what if the Iraqis don't want
you to stay if the prime minister says
you need to go will US troops pull out
and also NATO allies are pulling out
why aren't US troops pulling out so
we'll take all those one step at a time
there's a few of procedural mechanisms
hurdles if you will that the Iraqi
government would need to go through we
remain in constant contact with them on
that I think it's fair to say that many
Iraqis recognize the strategic
importance of our partnership with them
whether it's training and advising their
military to become more effective on the
field of battle or it's working together
with them to defeat Isis coalition I
think the vote the other day shows the
support of the most Iraqis before our
presence in the country as you know most
Kurds and most Sunnis did not show and
knows she is who did vote and many of
them voted that the threat of their own
lives by Shia militia groups even in the
last few days we still see Iraqis on the
streets protesting their government due
to corruption and the malign influence
of Iran
so those sentiments those feelings have
not gone away so I think at the end the
day working with you with the with the
Iraqi people you'll find that our
presence is important for both their
country ours you also asked about
partners I've talked to many of our
partners in Iraq who are part of the D
Isis coalition and many Europeans they
are fully supportive of us they are
fully with us I've been told by them
that the some of the movements they are
taking or simply forgot for with regard
to force protection we're doing some of
that as well
it does not mark or signal any
withdrawal from Iraq or the mission the
mission writ large the range of options
that were under consideration can you
give us any sense of you know how many
other options are under consideration
did you support any other ones and was
one option to not take this strike
inside Iraq which would have clearly men
I'm not going to speak to any options or
anything we present to the president as
you know it's kind of how I approach
things I will tell you that options we
presented were all options that we
support it and believe we could deliver
on and would be effective and with any
time we deliver an option we always list
pros and cons hey whether you're we're
there multiple options that you would
have considered that that you would have
supported I'm not sure I understand the
question where are other options that
you supported in addition to this one
well look there are there are always a
wide range of options our duty is to
narrow them down and to to ones that are
consistent with the president's guidance
or expectation or can meet the political
end state we're trying to achieve so
again we had a full panoply of options
available and we present them and we
portray them as we do about the nice
moving their troops doesn't mean that
you couldn't guarantee that security
especially with a an air protection or
did you ask them to move yeah no I don't
think so I I know in one case in
particular was just a matter of us being
able to move in additional US forces
into a confined space that was being
occupied by some of the international
trainers partners on the ground it was
just a logistical issue thank you can
you clarify the attack soleimani was
planning was that days or weeks away I
think it's more fair to say days for
sure the US legally obliged withdraw
from Iraq if told by the Iraqi
government to go I'm not going to
speculate we're not there yet there's
been no that has happened to the best of
my knowledge and as those events unfold
we'll address them and we'll have all
the right legal experts to advise us on
that mr. secretary you said the u.s. is
not seeking
Iran I think the question most people
want an answer to is how close are we to
war with Iran and specifically how would
you characterize Iranian military
movements over the past several days
yeah it is true we're not seeking war
with Iran I think the what happens next
depends on them I think we should expect
that they will retaliate in some way
shape or form either through their
proxies as they've been doing now for
for how many years or bio and or with by
their by their own hand and so we take
this one step at a time we're prepared
for any contingency and and then we will
respond appropriately to whatever they
do oh you know we watch them very
closely we see their movements I don't
want to get more into that because it
starts getting into intelligence issues
so I'll just leave it at that mr.
secretary you talked about being ready
for potential conflict here in case a
lot of Italians if they don't owe it our
partners in the region is that enough to
warrant a US response look you know Lee
I'm not going to comment on I'm not
gonna hypothesize or comment speculate
but we are standing there to defend not
only our interests but those of our
allies and partners and I want to
reassure them that were there with them
as well
two points to follow up on if I may you
we have talked about Iran needs to
deescalate my first question is does the
u.s. have any obligation to de-escalate
or is absolutely in Iran's court my
second question you have said several
times in the past couple of days that
you will follow international law on
potential war crimes I think let me set
that aside I think everyone would expect
you exactly that my question is not
hypothetical president is out there with
his position if you get an order would
you resigned from office rather than
violate the law Barbara I'm not gonna
get into some hypothetical that you're
portraying here I'm fully confident that
the president is not going to the
commander-in-chief will not give us an
illegal order and and as I said the
United States military will as it always
has
obey the laws of armed conflict and
escalation does the u.s. have any
responsibility or obligation to also
deescalate or is that in your views only
in Iran we have not we're not the ones
that have escalated this over the past
arguably 40 years and certainly over the
past several months it's been a run
through its proxies and it consistently
escalated this in terms of the size
scale scope of their attacks so we
reached the point where we had to act in
self-defense
we had to take appropriate action so at
this point as I've said a few times now
the ball is in their court what they do
next will determine what happens in the
subsequent moves Thank You mr. secretary
I would like to ask you before the
attack against custom Soleimani have you
been and consultations with your
partners in the region I mean the GCC
countries of Israel if you have informed
them that this operation is going to
take place today at this moment yeah I'm
not going to get into the details of our
consultations on any matter with other
countries obviously we've been talking
about our force posture in Iraq for some
time our concerns about Iranian actions
or the actions that they are inspiring
resourcing or directing through its
militias but I'm not going to get any
into any details
: count your yeah
Mach gonna get into the details or calls
we that vote was legitimate that
resolution calling on us forces to leave
was legitimate and then separately on
the issue of you said that you expect
Iran to retaliate
are there any off ramps to this crisis
or do you expect that we're heading
towards this military confrontation on
the first question I won't characterize
it any any differently than what many
other people have characterized in many
experts and that is know unbinding and
we know there are other there are
mechanisms by which they would have to
act I'm not an expert on the Iraqi
government so I characterize it the way
I did with you all the other day is
non-bonding with regard to the off-ramps
there's a big off ramp sitting in front
of Tehran right now and that is to
de-escalate to message us that they want
to sit down and talk without
precondition by the way to the United
States about a better way forward a for
a way forward which would constitute a
new a new mode of behavior by Iran where
they behave more like a normal country
and that would one could presume free up
free them up from economic sanctions and
allow the Iranian people to pursue the
life they want to live and that is one
with freedom and prosperity and all
those things that most human beings want
after pressure from Iran as the Iraqi
government prevented the US military
from using certain capabilities within
the country hampering operations in any
way there they have taken some actions
in the past and it hampered some of our
operations with regard to airspace and
things like that but nothing that we
weren't eventually able to work through
with them and is that happening
currently there's there's nothing
they're doing right now that is
hampering our operations to the best of
my knowledge so what would just oppress
you a little bit more on this what would
constitute a binding order from the
Iraqi government because there seems to
be a disconnect from what Prime Minister
is telling an ambassador to ler and
other and heads of state from Europe
about implementing this resolution of
the Iraqi parliament and
the Pentagon says has been communicate
or hasn't been community I think that's
a great question for the Iraqi Prime
Minister but are you does that mean that
you are not taking his his communication
about the implementation of that
parliamentary resolution on its face in
terms of what he's actually saying the
best of my knowledge I haven't received
any communication from him or the Iraqi
government about about the legislation
or about an order or a request to
withdraw US forces top generals would
contribute to the case of the escalation
you're asking Iran to deescalate now
would the u.s. respond in such a manner
if one of your top generals was killed
in a third country well let's take a
look at history solemn a knee was a
terrorist leader of a u.s. designated
foreign terrorist organization he's been
conducting terrorist activities against
us and our coalition partners for over
20 years he has the blood of hundreds of
Americans soldiers on his hands and
wounded thousands more and then we could
talk about all the mayhem east cause
with against the Syrian people the
people of Lebanon even his own people in
Iran he is responsible in the Kurds
force for for the killing of Iranian
people so this sense that somehow taking
somebody who by the way over the last
few months had planned orchestrated and
or resourced attacks against the United
States that resulted in the killing of
American and the siege of our embassy in
Baghdad and was in bag Baghdad to
coordinate additional tax to somehow
suggest that he wasn't a legitimate
target I think is fanciful he was
clearly on the battlefield he was
conducting or preparing planning
military operations he was a legitimate
target and with his time was due
can you give it a little bit of a
preview of what you're gonna tell
Congress tomorrow a this in terms of how
much detail will you be given willing to
give members that you're having thus far
I told the public in terms of the sky's
size scope and eminence you know what
you were aware how skeptical people are
the eminent threat issue you're there in
2003 when you heard all that so what was
temper expectations what we what are you
prepared to disclose the Congress first
of all much of my messaging to Congress
will be the same as what I'm delivering
to you all here in terms of my views on
the policy the this the the broader
regional situation in history obviously
with members of Congress we can go into
a classified set we will be in a
classified setting and be able to share
more but the exquisite intelligence that
we're talking about that led to the
decision to that was I should say one of
the factors that led to the decision to
strike at Soleimani is it is only shared
with a handful of members the so-called
gang of eight and so they are getting
that briefing this afternoon and and and
they will have access to that but most
members will not have access to that you
talked about the these the the
commanders in the region I should say
globally are taking all appropriate
force protection measures relevant to
their situation the threat that they're
that they're receiving the readiness of
their troops etc so I'm confident that
our commander is going to do the right
thing on the ground okay thank you all
very much
because of you originally from the Ave
Maria
[Applause]